oh man Jimmy Wong oh man Jimmy Wong in
the house this is it we're doing it we
arrived dude thanks for coming out man
thanks for inviting me to the quarter
digital studio the podcast studio I've
never been here in this current state so
it's pretty exciting
yeah we've got some on the wall now yeah
yeah we do have a lot to talk about
so much to talk how long have we all
known each other let's start there since
2011 years Oh 2011 eight years yeah I
first moved to LA in 2011 Clint visited
that year when we played Minecraft on
Sam's computer it was right when
minecraft came out the same year that we
dressed as Minecraft as Steve for
Halloween and everyone thought we were
Legos because that we were too early and
we went to the Old Spice guys house for
yeah yeah wait Terry Crews with the
other guy other guy yeah the original
Terry Crews oh the man on the horse got
you got you
yeah but that's how yeah 2011 that's
when I first moved to LA that's what you
guys have been here for two years I
think at that point maybe yeah roughly
yeah I just over Clint digging a pit in
Minecraft first diamond digging a hole
yeah I don't know I didn't know anybody
there's like 12 people all gaming in
this room and I'm like alright guys I'm
just gonna dig this pit and like whoever
wants the help I'm over in his corner
doing this play I wanted to like do
something cool clearly is impressive and
then I remember like I remember you were
sitting like in the corner over here
like yeah you were right behind me I was
at an l-shaped desk right in front of ya
Sam's computer was anika was to the left
of that or to the right of that and I
just remember getting good vibes from
you you like look over me but yes in the
game with you too yeah yeah my father's
memories from now or when Sam binge -
all about sir Galactica and eight
jack-in-the-box every night for two
months I joined him in the
jack-in-the-box pursuit I was playing
like Red Dead Redemption the first one
every single day
we're in living where was it it was
upstairs in this same yeah yeah in the
complex are we living in what is now the
closet that has the kitty litter and a
bunch of boxes yeah
yeah yeah Freddie and I shared the same
twin size bed for a year yeah we would
sleep sleep while it's to head yeah I
was in the back area
it's like creating like a channel around
that where it's just video you guys
sleeping you know somebody titled to
Long's maker right yeah I stopped him
from snoring I've told people this I
trained him how to stop snoring that
entire year how because every single
time he would start snoring it was
because it was you know like you snore
when you're in a different position and
like you're you know it gets like Cott
you're yeah you know in a different
angle or whatever so every time frames
start snoring because my foot was right
next to his head I'll just be like a
friendly nudge to the shoulder but
essentially I start training to the
point where if he didn't want to get
booted he would have to sleep a certain
way and by the end of the year he
stopped snoring because he just never
found himself in the position that he
would snore in because I was booed him
any other spot is pain yeah what's mine
too because he had a bunk bed right we
had this thing was just all storage
because it was like two feet from the
ceiling that's all a load is he goes
back there and also because the walls
back there aren't all the way up to the
top you were sleeping in the top bunk
you could just see out into the rest of
the kitchen maybe even to the next room
go away but hold on you saying it was
two feet from the ceiling though yeah
well I'm like a foot of like you could
peek over you have like two feet from
the top of the wall to the ceiling and
then the funk that was like a foot below
that so if you just sat up your head
with almost such a ceiling I just see
doubt every day I'd rather do that and
like sleep like a frickin mummy dude
well I Freddie not just figured it out I
guess we liked it for for that
accommodation and that was a full year
and then we moved down the hallway to
where you eventually lived as well do
you buy about a new bed yes we
definitely new beds at that point I
think I've switched beds like three or
four times in LA now it's pretty
annoying moving a bed is pain in the ass
hmm they say you should spend the money
in a good mattress that you won't ever
regret it yes I agree with that actually
now having a much better mattress and
friggin I still want to and like
I'll go there's room and be like oh my
gosh I needed by their mattress I can't
fathom buying a mattress online like how
do you go ahead and purchase like a
multi-thousand dollar mattress that
relying on without gauging it yeah right
I mean I did I just Amazon they're just
like hey this one's comfy it's got some
stars on us Oh was it an expensive
mattress in bucks
that's not a very expensive mattress as
far as mattresses go how expensive you
can get up to like 5k yeah a good
mattress is like two to three thousand
yes yeah
once again if you think about it worth
it yeah that's why I spent a lot of
money on to get a really nice chair too
because I spend the majority of my day
sitting in it yeah sure
probably eight hours a day minimum oh no
oh how much money I spend on it so I
bought a Herman Miller Aeron and that's
like anywhere from a thousand to fifteen
hundred dollars is that the one that has
like the spine for the back kind of got
like a spine it's it's you if you go
into a lot of corporate offices and
stuff these days every single chair is
this share it's just like a very oh I
know what you're talking about Miller
chair - it's an open box deal so 60% off
Oh ray yeah would you find it medicine
seating comm it's the only one they had
really something bought it didn't like
it and gave it back
yeah I agree though yeah you spend most
of your time in bed and in a chair if
you're doing computer work also iPhones
recently they do this thing now every
week I don't know if yours does this
worth it will tell you screentime yeah
yeah well guys is average usage on the
phone every day three hours wow that's
good oh I am 200% that Nikko really Wow
six hours a day to be fair yeah it
doesn't necessary measure when your
phone is just on all right if you're
having a phone conversation that's
screen time if your phone is on and off
the side screen time if you're eating
lunch is playing YouTube or account
that's all you engaging yeah yeah for me
it says like the the Matt the most
things that happen or I get like text
message notifications or like YouTube
notifications and that's it tell you
when you pick up your phone and all that
stuff - yeah so I don't feel that bad
cuz my life does center around the
internet yeah don't they all don't all
our lives
clean what's your screen time I think
it's like an hour and a half or so what
where's your phone take it out let's
look right now
I try and keep it down like it
interference so it's gonna be under
settings and if you scroll down on the
second bar it says screen time and then
you can okay so this is like a nickname
last seven days yeah oh nevermind I'm at
four hours 23 minutes a day thank
goodness bad
that's actually pretty heavy but it was
tell you what you did the most of I did
call networking for 20 hours last week
reading for seven and creativity for
four but I mean isn't it all creative
well depending I'm at 38 minutes a day
so it's in under settings go down to
screen time everyone with an iPhone
going to do this is actually really
fascinating this is just today I think
oh no last seven days 38 minutes a day I
try and keep it Wow off but if you look
at Clint's phone his battery level is
currently at 13% for some reason at
10:00 in the morning I hadn't charged it
charge it last night
so yeah Klinger true truly the the least
user of the those are the the least
active user of your phone dude I I took
off Facebook Twitter and Instagram off
my phone because I'll just get I would
find myself just like scrolling what am
i doing
and like most recently I've just found
myself going home and practicing
cinema4d and doing renders and like that
that is like productive fun yeah for me
you know so I and and eventually you
know have a Instagram with photography
and whatnot so when I have pictures to
post I'll install Instagram another
picture of installing an app every time
you want to use it put a barrier esting
yeah you have to login every single time
verify two-factor oof well yeah I've
been on Facebook in like months yeah I'm
here
it feels good though that's interesting
I don't I never use Facebook for
Facebook can I use Facebook than most
for is messenger and then I have a fan
page and then that I'll post to or
stream on and do stuff um dude you're on
those those Facebook gaming streams
Facebook gaming streams yeah a bunch of
creators on the if you guys have noticed
are working with Facebook this year to
basically stream on their pages
Facebook's trying there and of course
like everyone else enter the
Arina best of luck to everyone it's a
tough world out there I've been on those
talked out streams with Freddie yes
that's right it's key from tarkov yeah
you guys play a lot of that interesting
it's not my yeah it looks like a really
great great mountain think it's my my
steez it's cool real can have things
they like yeah the same thing as
everybody else's yeah yeah that's why
I'm like cool you play whatever you want
if you want to just run through
doki-doki literature Club over and over
again you do that you do that I've heard
good things about it yeah it's I mean if
you grew up playing any sort of games
that are similar in nature like this
because it's got like a dating sim vibe
then you'll really enjoy it because it
takes that and like messes with the
format gotcha
talking about exactly maybe she install
Facebook so the thing that you need to
do what don't tell us what the deal now
the thing is that tomorrow or going in
for portraits at the YouTube space uh
apparently they hired a really good
photographer the guy who does all the
portraits for the people that get Oscars
yeah he's gonna be taking our picture
soon maybe we'll be holding Oscars as
well who knows that way you all are
unshaven it's gonna shave before
tomorrow right because at 4:30 today
jaqen Christians favorite barber is
coming into the studio to give us trims
Wow yeah so I let I knew this three
months ago so I can Arthur Morgan like
full-on Western yeah what are you gonna
do Clint I don't know I think it's gonna
like a cardinal it's gettin it's gettin
a little Haggard so it's yeah it's I
think I think maybe just a trim you
don't want to look too much like
PewDiePie honestly trying to measure
what PewDiePie looks like um kind of
looks like you right now see it with no
beard I get I get the Snowden Snowden
vibes right and then maybe with the
beard is PewDiePie I don't know if any
that's good I think a good German would
do you well right just cleaning it up
getting some straighter edges agreed not
not like making a full like don't go
like the Jake route and actually like
make a thing out of it I'm not hit those
hairs off that upper looks good on Jake
I don't know so much about oh my grandma
said that to me once what it's like you
gotta get that hair off your upper lip
so you got to turn that mustache get
those hairs off your upper lip oh no
okay grandma
I'm a fashion grandma she's like she
really knows a lot about money yeah so
what do we want to get into guys we can
talk about many things here yeah mm
let's start from the beginning
let's a week we're touching on it right
we were like talking about when we all
met about eight years ago yeah we want
to keep going up and like just hail hit
all the moments and stuff yeah I think
this is a perfect opportunity for Jimmy
to give us a little history lesson on
what the heck is going on with all the
different people like wait are you part
are you node or are you rocket jump or
you corridor or you put a Punisher or
Jimmy wait aren't you part of feast of
fiction or are you a part of rocket jump
oh my just Freddie's brother Yeah right
he's not my dad he still get that
comment today I can't believe he's not
your dad what yeah years apart right
yeah we're a year and a half apart not
even two years apart mom got busy so
let's break it down back when I moved to
Los Angeles Freddie and Sam and Nico and
Brandon we're all living in the same
loft and this is before Clinton you I
think clay may have known of all of us
let me specifically I was watching I was
was in Georgia and all the same yeah I
wasn't I was in Atlanta watching your
guys's videos and stuff so Freddie
graduated from USC alongside Brandon and
you guys are coming from Minnesota
mm-hmm fun fact Brandon actually never
graduated oh he didn't yeah oh well
that's great
now we know he had well he had four
credits left and he didn't want to take
another semester just for one class
seems like I don't write the number of
times I've shown someone my degree from
college is a big fat zero you know and
that's after nine years now being in the
business so those so Freddie and Brandon
were working together on their YouTube
stuff and so Sam and Nico were as well
and when I came into the equation I
moved in with Freddie because I had
nowhere else to live and the rent was
obviously pretty good for being in this
part of town and that's at that time of
the history especially being split five
ways yes split five ways free and I
sharing the same bed and when you got
Freddie W and then you got corridor yeah
known as quarterback then or is that
sort of yeah right or actually started
in 2009 and Brandon was actually briefly
a part of corridors oh my god am i right
for like 500 bucks yeah because he
didn't end up not wanting to like do
what we were doing
freelance visual effects yeah you
weren't doing YouTube or anything like
that yeah yeah I think that was sort of
the the original combination right so
Freddy and Brandon obviously knew visual
effects as well and you guys were very
good at it so well in the first
collaborations you guys did was that
Modern Warfare to shoot which is right
outside the studio and that was like the
beginning of a lot of the pattern the
videos to continue so Freddy and Brandon
were on the quest of doing like a viral
ask short video every single week while
Sam and Nick were focused on doing
longer form more of the effects-heavy
but like IOT I would call it more
cinematic stuff whereas the Freddy W
channel with Brandon was much more gaggy
in a lot of ways and when I came in I
think they had like 2 million
subscribers already on YouTube they're
off to a great start so when I came in I
was like you know I don't want to be a
part of YouTube there's no real acting
on YouTube and to be fair back then the
only acting I saw was like Shane Dawson
doing skits mm-hmm and that was a very
different Shane Dawson than Shane Dawson
of today and I saw that stuff and I was
like this isn't acting this is just
jokey nothing serious about it I'm a
serious actor I studied drama so I came
to LA do acting for a full year and
during that time I lived with everyone
watched their channels he continued to
explode in popularity and growth and
doing all sort of stuff around the time
I think frame bran did their like a US
tour in that big van that's when they
came out to Georgia yes
and I met up with Freddy and Brandon and
Brett came out - oh really
and we filmed like what was it the last
shot it was like they're like yes it was
the ending of a movie right yeah yeah
Brett was the guy running away spilling
the cocaine and so that was my first
time being in like a video and like I
knew I got visited you guys before like
with the minecraft gaming and whatnot so
that was my first experience yeah so
from there after that after a year of
not doing anything online I was having
minimal success as an actor I joined the
Union to the movie but it wasn't like
yeah I was in John dies at the end
that's the first movie I did that got me
taft-hartley into the Union which is
like basically saying like they're just
inviting you up kind of much it's like
pulling you in the Varsity without
having to go through JV so after that
Freddy and Brandon and those guys did
the Kickstarter 4 vo game high school
season 1 and I started my cooking show
feast of fiction on you
- and I started doing music on YouTube
as well so this sort of stuff all
happened within the next two or three
years I decided at first I didn't want
to do acting on YouTube because again I
didn't think it was a place to seriously
act so I did music at first and the
music for a while and that I released a
viral video I think was the third video
I put out ended up going viral is a
response to this girl from UCLA that was
being pretty racist towards Chinese
people in library and so I released a
song to that it got like national
acclaim it blew me into the spotlight I
had no idea what I was doing so I felt
like I was like in a tidal wave but sort
of tumbling in the middle you know not
really in control of what was happening
but enjoying the ride vo game high
school season 1 got filmed after that
this is when Freddie and brain were
still working together and after I think
at that point you guys were you guys had
done prism or sync it was one of the two
right you were starting to work on one
of those two probably sink because prism
was like right the beginning of our
YouTube stuff whereas like this would be
based on where we are in the timeline
it's like two years into our YouTube
careers yeah sorry yeah so so everyone
was working on bigger scale and cooler
stuff and I think at this point Clint
had moved out I'd moved out here doing
the VFX NSYNC yeah I'm doing the effects
the effects on sync and then like carbon
warfare - at the time it took like eight
months that was the first thing I finish
when I came out and then right after
that I think I hopped onto V effects for
sync right what's the timeline yeah that
was also around the time that you guys
met Josh leak Y yeah and who was gonna
be a very important part of this story
later on yeah he did the I did a free
trailer for us for sync little did we
know that how he nagged West yeah it's
like holy moly that guy has some credits
under his belt for trailer edits yes so
generously acquires a trailer editor
that he did he saw Sam and Nico I saw
Freddie and was like you know I like
what these guys are doing I think what
they're doing is the future so I'm gonna
go in and help them and do some stuff
just for free for pro-bono to get
involved with it see the world check it
out for myself he's very much a
marketing kind of guy and Mark like very
much business savvy he edited the
trailer for Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
he did the Chinese trailer for the force
awakens he did a lot of parts of the
Caribbean work as well as a lot stuff
with Disney and came in and did some
stuff with you guys he'll come back into
the equation later on so at that point
is when I believe Freddy and Brinn
were about to go their separate ways and
I was watching it was interesting
because I know a lot of people that are
watching this probably saw the clip
where Brandon talks about why he left
Freddy W hmm and I was very intrigued
because I'd never heard this side of it
from him my so my understanding of the
situation was that Freddy and bran just
wanted to do different things right ray
wanted to go into more long-form
storytelling and movies and stuff as is
I think very typical and normal for film
a lot film students know one director is
actually just people in general and only
one the become directors and bran was
going into the more game development
side and so as a result it was like cool
we're just gonna go in separate ways
brain took over the fray that be to
channel and was able to really stuff
there and then renamed it the brain in
JLA and then Freight took for a W turned
into rocket jump which was a larger
conglomerate of him and a couple of our
partners to make these long-form
projects but when I saw the Brandon
video he said the moment that he stepped
on the set and saw a trailer for an
actor that that was it that was not what
he wanted and what was important to him
and for me as an actor I wasn't uh I
wasn't like it wasn't that guy was
offended or affronted by that because
this is my dream is to keep doing bigger
and cooler stuff because when I saw a
trailer on set to me that signified wow
this is great this is the culmination of
all my hard work that I get to you know
be an actor on set and be an actor and
part of something that's really big and
that's sort of what happens
accommodations wise is actors will get
the trailer there will be a green room
there's me crafty there's me all this
stuff and for me it was really new
really fresh I'm really exciting so it's
interesting to see the double parallels
there or not the parallel is just the
the difference in how Brandon saw that
and how someone as the person that was
in the thing SOT mm-hmm and I think
that's actually really it's just like a
very different world for me coming into
it as a performer because I cherish that
opportunity a lot because as an actor
it's not like you know the reason I
started doing YouTube is because you
want more control over your own career
and you want to do this stuff that you
want to do and acting in LA especially
as a minority back then it was hard to
find roles at all so here I go getting
offered a role that's basically the one
of the three main roles of a show that
has a romantic love interest kiss as a
person on-screen all this stuff that was
breaking
racial boundaries that really hadn't
been done before to me it meant the
world because it meant that I got to
represent myself and my culture and my
people and to
you know like if I was a kid growing up
and I saw Ted Wong on screen I would be
so happy because I never would have I
never really had that otherwise who I
had shortround from Indiana Jones
I had Jackie Chan I had Bruce Lee and
like immediately Jackie Chan Bruce Lee
very very cool people but Bruce Lee was
gone before I was really alive and Jet
Li and Jackie Chan as awesome as they
were and never you know you're a young
kid growing up and you don't want to get
bullied and you want girls to like you
and you don't ever see someone that
looks like you on screen having success
talking to a girl you see the James
Bond's out there you see all the heroes
you see people in the black and the
Latino communities I can tonio Banderas
and and Wesley Snipes getting all the
ladies and so and it seems like a really
shallow thing but as a kid it means a
lot because it's just representation so
the fact that I got to be in the trailer
on set and be on the same level as these
other people that I you know for the
longest time could never equate myself
with and a highly romantic love interest
I had to kiss on screen all this stuff
like that made me so happy and very like
grateful to be there so hmm
brands reaction makes a lot of sense to
me if he doesn't want to be in the film
world because that I think just like not
seeing something like that now they're
construing it as negative or not the
thing that you want it doesn't mean that
it's a bad thing necessarily right
because there's some people it's very
important to him it just wasn't that
important so that's something I never
really knew about Brandon so it's really
interesting to see that side of things
and I'm glad that he's doing game
development stuff too because I'm you
know I got to be a face model for one of
the one of the projects he's doing right
now and it's awesome to see the stuff
they're doing you can tell that there's
a lot of passion and love there for that
specific thing mmm so I think that's
like the big split that happened
fundamentally was you guys were working
with the collective at the time and
that's when know'd was created right
mm-hmm and I think gaming was the one
thing that kept everyone all tied
together yeah which is we all share a
love of video games that's where Freddy
and Brandon got their start is making
video game parodies essentially and
that's where we all did our stuff we
made video game parodies yeah except for
you cleaning a carpet warfare which is a
cardboard parody you know I did I did I
did my game parrot isn't my sleeping
dogs yeah enstein and that's right that
is just straight-up cinematic
interpretations but I I want to get into
what you just said though about you know
Brandon having his opinion and his
beliefs on you know his future
he's not interested in stuff with you
know what the hell is easy yeah I think
it was the very formalized like set in
like this is how we make stuff in
Hollywood kind of thing I think brain
has always been the kind of person that
likes to break out of that the you know
my create his own box kind of guy yeah
totally think outside that area so I
think that was mister felt confining or
something to him I don't know exactly
how he felt but I can understand where
he's going for well I remember same
being on set with Brandon and like we
would look around at how many people
would be standing around and like he and
I would be making fun of like the fact
that like a set would have like 30
people literally not doing anything
right but it wasn't until I was on
bigger sets I kind of realized why that
is and Schurz I mean there's definitely
sets that are on any efficient lee for
yeah but the other part of it is that
like when you're on set you are burning
so much money per minute of just
existing mm-hmm that extra people on the
hand doesn't really matter in terms of
cost what they matter for is like okay
cool the scenes done we need to set up a
new scene how fast can go and then they
do it in like five minutes versus taking
an hour yeah with like three people
running around someone grabbing a
c-stand and I shouldn't pee or whatever
no but I'm just saying like he has he
has his feelings on that like that's all
justified you had your feelings on
wanting to do the opposite wanting to go
down that route because as you just
think was the first time I did it right
yeah so for me seeing a trailer on set
wasn't like oh this is the system more
than me wasting money on this now is
more like what a cool opportunity I get
to like be treated a little more extra
special because I get represent and I
feel like now I have a more of a burden
on me to do a really good job what I'm
about to do so what I'm feeling is like
just because someone else had an opinion
that was opposite of yours doesn't mean
that like and especially if you looked
up to that person especially if you were
friends with that person like it doesn't
mean that like you have to have the same
opinion yeah it doesn't mean they're
wrong necessarily it doesn't mean always
have different opinions sometimes
opinions are fundamentally wrong I think
but the opinion of I don't want to work
on movie sets I'd rather make video
games and flipping that there's like you
can definitely have both and there's
nothing wrong with that did you feel
like a sense of like ah man like I
totally understand like a sense of
empathy for Brandon's decision like I
understand why and it's like
you felt like you were you ever
influenced by his decision to like see
that trailer me like this is lame and
like did it did it kind of like knock
down your ex the excitement and
experience you had
I think after hearing him talk about
that on the cast I was a little my first
reaction was just so being a little
upset which was like oh man this was
something that was really special to me
yeah I know it's really special to a lot
of people the fact that it was
formalized and that's what turned you
off of it is a bummer because I wish
maybe you know you understood how much
it meant to me to have that as an actor
yeah and that that was my approach to it
but I don't hold it against anyone you
know obviously because if you don't like
something you don't like something I
think everyone's out here to change the
world in different ways and how they
want to do it is completely subjective
and up to them absolutely ready and
those guys they want to make movies they
want to make films and I think
entertainment and storytelling is one of
the best ways to have an impact on the
world at large and so was gaming right
so Brandon went into game development
and that's also something that obviously
has a huge impact on everyone's lives
when node was created back again we're
talking on the twenty twelve thirteen
thirteen thirteen or fourteen thirteen
or fourteen right when no was created it
was something that everyone participated
in and was successful enough to become
its own essentially independent venture
which says a lot about the fact that
everyone enjoyed gaming enough to still
participate in and still have an active
role in it and make it work and at the
same time everyone was still doing their
main passion for a core to digital it's
what's happening right now for Brandon
it's the game development and refrain
those guys it's moviemaking right and
for me it's acting and performing and
hosting and doing all that stuff so I
think what ended up happening and this
is something I wanted to talk about for
a long time is it's not like people we
all looked at each other and we're like
I hate you I don't want to work with you
ever again none of our things line up
it's just like when you become an adult
and I think at the time if you look at
the demographics YouTube was 13 to 17 I
think a lot of the people that are
listening to this like ask yourselves
were you between the ages of 13 to 17
when you started watching Freddy W
quarter digital rocket you have all that
stuff if the answer is yes then it
becomes a question of okay if your how
much are you gonna change from 13 to 17
what are you tastes like what are you
gonna love and
imagine how are you gonna change from
the age of 22 to 29 or whatever and how
are those shapes can taste gonna change
how are those wants gonna change and in
that case it's like Brandon started off
doing shorts really like that and wanted
to do game development
Coria digital started up doing VFX and
I'm doing cinematic stuff frayed up you
started doing out shorts and they want
to do movie length stuff right so all of
our tastes change but we're also mean
that we're not friends anymore I think
the problem was that when you grew up at
13 and you experienced what we started
doing and by the time you got to 17 did
you did your taste change did you want
to continue along the path that we all
chose or did you feel like you were
quote-unquote betrayed because someone
else had different ideas about what they
wanted to do because I think that's
where a lot of like Internet entitlement
comes from is like your taste may not
have changed so much from 13 to 17 or
what you expected didn't change so much
but for the people that were 22 to 29 I
need to make a living make themselves
happy have a life you know like earn you
know figure out how they're gonna
survive in the world without the comfort
of a family that could pay for their
rent and you know pay for their taxes
bills and all that stuff what are they
doing that's gonna change and I think
the problem is that fundamentally the
age difference makes you look at the
people above you and maybe not
understand that like oh they're just
doing what they want to do it makes them
happy I shouldn't hold them I shouldn't
I shouldn't make like I think the big
mess in their saying is people seeing
what happened to all of us going our
different directions and thinking that
there was some sort of fundamental split
where we all hate each other or don't
like each other where it's just like no
we're all just dudes living our lives
mm-hmm you from the youngest that may
not understand how that separates people
the older you get like it doesn't you
can't I wish you could be friends with
the same people for your whole life but
it's gonna change your life is like a
big tapestry and people are gonna weave
in and out of it and to expect that one
person is gonna be doing the exact same
thing at 22 that at 29 that you loved
when you were 13 is actually
unreasonable because if I asked by the
time that you get to that age and I say
hey whatever you're doing right now if I
like it you have to keep doing that for
the rest of your life
there'll be an awful thing to ask of
someone it's so it's like a selfish
thing you know it's like it feels
selfish but at the same time you don't
think you know better when you're that
young no and of course not no of course
not but it's like yeah it's like I'm
digging the vibes right now it's really
nice and like getting out of that
getting out going from comfort to
discomfort sucks yeah no one wants that
yeah yeah and like
for one person it might be comfort to
continued comfort by continuing the
thing they love doing but the other
person is like yo what about me yeah
like it's like I I know it's like but I
can't live my life for somebody else you
know yeah yeah yeah it totally I think a
lot of people that's what YouTube was
for a long time which was like cater to
your audience give them what they want
but the internet changed the algorithm
changed our own personal taste change
and to think if we were doing the same
thing if you told me that I was gonna be
acting in the same level of stuff seven
years ago that I'm doing today I would I
would hate it I'd be like no please
never I don't want to be doing the same
thing that's as an artist as someone
that's creative that's like one of the
most stifling things you could ask uh
someone you want to be challenged yeah
you wanna be challenged I think everyone
here has found different ways of doing
that so so I have always like considered
myself and you to in the way claim is
someone that can float between all these
groups of people and maintain positive
healthy relationships with all of them
and so as a result I think I have a good
perspective on where everyone's been I
see corridor digital as a company that
has now launched a very successful
patreon has an amazing vlog series has
some great employees under their arm
that all represent the brand and the
lifestyle really well and I think that's
awesome right like I see that as a great
natural evolution of where you guys
started at how you can grow your family
in a lot of ways I'm trying to do
similar stuff with my brand and all that
as well
I see rocketjump is a company that got
into making some of the big league stuff
they got to make two shows for hulu
dimension portal form rocket jam the
show they got to scale up the production
and they got to continue writing stories
the way they wanted to and now they're
writing a lot movies and getting you
know trying to go down that path which
is very hard but that's what they want
to do I see Clint is someone that goes
in and drops bombs everywhere you go
balls estonia smelly like bob's of
content right like when i'd clinton I
work together briefly at rocketjump for
the short steam we got a year right
about a year we got make a bunch of
choice but before that Clint was with
rocketjump making all sorts of different
videos across the years you made modern
warfare took carpel were 42.5 you did a
bunch of different stuff with Freddie
and by yourself project launching your
own baby on board all sorts of different
things and now you're now you've moved
over to corridor digital because rocket
jump is moved past to that model mm-hm
and now you get to do you know you get a
your own same passion here and evolve it
however you need to exactly
yeah I'm learning so much well about
everything always always learning like I
think that's something that I am gonna
have for the rest of my life is a
passion for learning and I'm I'm very
excited about it cuz like I'm always
trying to challenge myself always trying
to get better at what I'm doing and here
at corridor like it's same thing I'm
learning so much and just from like just
just from the VFX like angle of things
dude I've leveled up so much it's insane
like with with you know cinema 4d and
octane and everything and just messing
around and the thing is it's so much fun
mm-hmm it's so much fun and then having
to write shorts you know every two weeks
like that's super hard and at times it's
not fun you know but it is the best
challenge ever you know so it's like
it's something that I can always get I
can always get into a challenge you know
and like fine I can always get and fine
find like some happiness in a challenge
yeah I mean so then if I had to ask both
of you this question right now what are
you passionate about I think you just
answered it for you which is all writing
about challenges learning challenging
yourself growing to be a better smarter
whatever more capable person and making
cool content right yeah that's part of
it I'm also very passion about yoga
right now okay it's yeah so so I would
say that your physical and mental health
are both very important to you oh yeah
because that's something that yoga is
symbolic of totally yeah totally and
Yuka what would you say you are like
passions are I mean there's an easy
answer to that but the slightly more
complicated answer is I actually feel
like right now I'm a little bit in
between passions like great because
there's nothing wrong with that by the
way I think it's a natural evolution of
what happens with passion - thank you so
it can be a little bit uh disconcerting
um disorienting yeah cuz like for a long
time was all about like make explosive
viral shorts things that just get
millions people to watch I mean I'm
still about that obviously but like
having done that for eight years now
like
like okay done check you know it's like
yeah Robby Satan I need to keep doing it
as a business and still fun to do and I
enjoy it but it's not like it's not the
same passion I used to have for it in
the day it was like oh my gosh look at
this it's going it's it's doing this
thing it's the first or a few times ever
happy yes you just it's like hitting all
the neurons it's like stepping on the
moon for the first time is crazy
stepping on it for the second time still
crazy fourth time still crazy
yeah but twelfth time it's cool time
you're like getting super meta like what
if we hit a golf ball and then the other
end we have someone to hit this idiot
yeah can we bring a buggy up here yeah
oh we did cool like now it's a cool
again like right so that's kind of like
it's a little tricky there in like I'll
probably outgrow this but I feel like my
passion for making the big narrative
stuff has been killed a little bit by
the industry or my yeah just kind of by
the industry and realizing how hard it
is not just like the challenge was
making a movie isn't I mean writing
movies hard making movies hard but
that's not the challenge for me because
that's what my expertise is in I mean
I'm not a good movie writer like I can
write but I'm not good at it there's
very good cover you're a filmmaker and
but the challenge of the movie is
getting a producer that can really
produce the heck out of it right and
getting a distributor that knows what
the heck they're doing with the
marketing right into the right theaters
like if you want to make a film it's not
about just getting into the theaters you
has to be a worldwide distribution
international thing you have to know how
the marketing you guys are cut trailers
for it you have to spend a lot of money
making sure that people know what it is
they don't confuse it for something else
alright all your aperture design
specific contracts have specific
marketing requirements like there's a
whole layer like layers upon layers of
like actual if you wanted to have them a
couple million dollars in your budget or
more there's so many layers to that that
I'm not aware of as a filmmaker because
that's not my thing
like that as I've become aware of that
now because I've started to encroach on
that industry is something like whole
this is not what I thought moviemaking
was this is not really my my thing I
haven't trained at all that learning is
this right yeah yeah yeah a lot of us I
think are creatives at heart
specifically yeah but like that's what
the other angles for like that's what
someone specializes and do
so that you don't have to like be a
master in that area and I think it's
just finding the right person or the
right team to cover that zone yeah you
know I think the big problem and this is
another thing talking to again all of
the prior 13 to 17 year olds that are
now growing into adults and even the
generations below that if you're 13 to
17 now which is we say all this stuff
like we just got to find the right
person that in itself is single greatest
challenges I've met over nine years now
in LA which is I can't tell you how many
people I've met that have made promises
or seem like the right fit and a week
down the line a year down the line
sometimes multiple years down the line
that you find that they were absolutely
the wrong person and betrayed you or
they hurt you or they stole from you or
they just weren't the right fit or
they're in it for something less the
more about themselves and like there's
salt like you said any coat sure there's
so much that goes into making anything
that I think the convenience of being
able to pick up your phone and watch
anything in the world
dilutes a lot of how people visualize
the difficulties of Agnon realities of
content that they're watching mm-hmm and
I think a lot of the entitlement that
people get comes from that too which is
like you pick up your phone you watch
anything you want you don't need to
think about the blood sweat and tears
hundreds of hours pain heartbreak money
loss the relationships destroyed that
one that we're spent in making that
thing that you just watched and like
math thumbs down yeah yeah it's very
quickly judged and then and then you
type in the comments I want more of this
why can't you give me more of this I
deserve you know it's it's not you're
not saying I deserve this but you're
essentially like I've seen so many
comments being like I I liked it back
when the old days when those like this I
want this because I want it you know
which is like well what about the person
making it that has to spend all the time
to do it are they can they not want
something for themselves and if they
don't give you that then who are you
holding it against are you holding it
against them for not giving you what you
want are you even asking yourself am I
being unreasonable and asking for this
over and over again like there's so many
layers to that too the Internet's a wild
place yeah everything is just pure like
unfiltered human it'd yeah yeah yeah I
think one thing I've learned about the
Internet
large there's an opening of a sentence
is to see change is to see a change in
culture mm-hmm like if you want things
to be different the only way to achieve
it you can't do it two rules you can't
do it through systems you can't do it
through reporting like the only way to
actually change something is to
fundamentally change the culture around
it and that kind of comes with change
the education you know changing people's
mindset some things yeah because it has
to be something that everybody holds
inside of them where it's like okay like
I might react to it this way but
culturally speaking now as a citizen of
the internet I've learned that these
things are important for example to
creators or to content I'm getting like
you know there's I'm seeing live of
culture shift around advertisements for
example on the internet you know people
that talk about like ad blocking you
know all the websites that go to and
please my list this somebody made a an
AI that could filter out any sponsored
segments in a video and then like people
o sick when you're gonna release it but
then there's a fair amount of comments
and I was happy to see is being like
guys just put this out there how are you
expecting to have this content made if
you're going to even remove like the in
video sponsors you know sponsors that
are directly supporting the people whose
content you're consuming it's like and
for the most part individual
sponsorships really aren't that bad not
that obtrusive to me yeah so I have a
podcast now with Josh leak wise the
trailer editor that we talked about
earlier and we have two sponsors for the
show one's a retailer it sells it's
about Magic the Gathering one of them is
a sponsor that sells cards online and
the other is a guy a company that makes
like products like play mats and all
that stuff and we spend about you know
we spot cast for about an hour and the
first five minutes are intro to the show
what we're talking about in the
shout-out to our sponsor mm-hmm so five
minutes I have an hour that's 5 oz 60 is
pretty slow on percentage and the number
one up the comet usually is the
timestamp we said this starts here hmm
and to me it's always been so confusing
which is like and the people be like
thank you you're the real savior below
all these replies to it and to me it's
so bizarre being like okay I get it if
you don't want to listen to it maybe
you've listened this podcast for three
years
you've heard the same spiel over and
over again that's fine you can skip over
it all you want it's in the you have the
ability to literally click past it but
that step is even so far that people
need to find someone else that's done it
for them and then that person to them is
touted as like a you know thank you so
much which is so interesting because
it's like you wouldn't even have this
content if it wasn't for the fact that
we couldn't make it happen without these
sponsors right
like Josh Lee quite dropped his day job
in order to do this podcast full-time so
when I see that stuff it always strikes
me as like again it's not ungratefulness
necessarily because I think that's
assuming too much about the person
that's not liking it it's just a lack of
understanding about why it needs to
exist and why it's there mm-hmm like you
turn on the TV you watch a TV show great
that yeah they don't yell at sponsors in
that but they take a commercial break
three times and they run like it's 23
minutes out of 37 minutes of our pure
commercials it's like there are always
things like this that exists I think
people just said in the name that can
like sort of contextualize them in the
internet and how that economy works for
creators yeah well I wasn't saying I
think TV commercials are the worst
because oh yeah that is like a long
general audience that's like as general
we have to reach everyone you know to it
and they also slap it in the middle of
the show and they take huge breaks to
watch them right it's like they crank up
the volume and it's like oh that's so
annoying man imagine if you watch a
Shane Dawson video three times during
the video it cut to seven minutes of
commercials like you would be screaming
yeah you and watch it anymore is it so
bad that they spend the minute being
like thank you to Nashville calm or
thank you to this mattress for
sponsoring this episode go lie on the
mattress it's nice that is somehow so
offensive to some people that they just
can't watch it it's crazy man but I do
think that's it like ad blockers and all
that stuff it's given people a little
way to fight back it's like because it's
always about finding that balance right
because you can go way too heavy on the
ads and the sponsors like they have in
television and then you have to you know
bounce back from that but like you have
to be careful that your bounce back
doesn't bounce back too far yeah it's
all about that understanding it's all
about developing that culture like
here's manners this is what's polite
right this you know it's like every kind
of eventually gets there they agree upon
it's like this is okay
we all accept this it lets people
everybody exists on both side
yeah yeah you just got to keep hammering
at home until it gets there yeah it's
yeah I think one of the most valuable
things I learned from Josh who is I
admittedly to me like a marketing genius
which is like you if you have a talking
point if you have something that you
need to people to remember you just have
to say it multiple times mm-hmm and you
have to keep hammering at home in the
same convincing way which is like look
we when these lights you have on out
here they cost money its electricity we
have someone editing this podcast we
have all of us here today doing stuff
for this podcast it wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for people on patreon it wouldn't
exist you know if you have you found
that we've given you value over the
years and you want to provide back in
any way then this is how you're doing it
that's the culture of what has been
created because of things like patreon
and donations on Twitch subscriptions
all that stuff like merch merch yeah
like we're not doing this just to like
run away with money and you know like
Scrooge McDuck it like no we're doing
all of this stuff oftentimes at a loss
and it's only made possible because we
have other people out there that can
help support the content in the same way
that you might go to the store and buy
you know a candy bar if you like a candy
bar company that's an awful comparison
but it's the same idea like if I went to
the store and I saw corridor digital
plush merch a bit cool I know if I buy
this I'm helping them out in the way and
I'm getting some value back from it yeah
I think like the people who actually
spend money like the patreon xand like
you know any any any other any other
what yeah the merch whatnot it was like
the true oh geez you know those are the
guys who are like really helping out and
oh by far they are the most for me the
patrons of our podcasts are the most
value people in my life by far yeah I
think the problem was the internet
started with absolute free content and
that's what we set the culture as
originally I think you've made a really
good point with the culture thing the
original culture was just like you get
this for free all of it yeah constantly
and the moment that people are like hey
I might is it okay if I ask for a little
something I was like you know we want it
for free I just I can't eat lunch no
like that's like what a god I feel
really fast yeah the backlash was so
weird and fierce meanwhile you still had
people you know doing Kickstarter's and
suffer things so people still got it it
just takes I think it took a lot of time
in there I think we're finally wrapping
around to getting there
yeah and I've seen cultural shifts
happen already like for example
crediting people people get credited way
more than yeah sooo full credits editor
producer like every try guys video I see
those guys understand like they have
their producers or writers and all the
PAS even all in the credits of all their
videos heck even on reddit when just
like a cool picture gets posted at this
point people post a photographer in
their Instagram yeah maybe it's not like
the first comment and the thread but
it's there it's there and I've seen a
lot people being like hey I came here
exactly for this
I'm oftentimes in reply to that comment
you know it's great that makes me happy
yeah because I mean people people want
to feel I think at a base level people
want to feel important people want to
feel like they're there doing something
and when you throw credit their way it's
like sweet thanks I'm glad that you
recognized my hard work yeah and like it
goes a long way it's such a small thing
but it really goes a long way you know
yeah I think there's a current backlash
as well to what people are deeming
outraged culture and it has a big wide
blanket to what that means it's either
something happened and you thought it
was offensive and you're outraged or
something like you weren't credited as
an artist and you posted about it and
you were outraged in the word outraged
isn't the right word for every situation
but I think people have a backlash style
rich culture because they're like you
guys are just overreacting about
everything culture judgment culture and
all that stuff I think the big thing is
like again if we didn't talk about it
and why it needs to happen and get in a
way outraged about it we're just gonna
get screwed in the long run then things
are never going to change so there is a
necessary part of speaking up about
something that's incorrect or making
sure that the person gets credited like
that credited stuff wouldn't be
happening if people in the comments were
pissed off about it right if more than
like whoa hey you just stole this from
someone you need to give them credit and
that's like a great thing to fight for
but it wouldn't happen that people
didn't raise their voice and say
something about it so there is a
necessary part of outraged culture that
has to happen if you want to actually
enact a positive change I do think that
like I I agree I agree with you on that
cuz like that makes sense there are
cases though where it's 20 why why are
you why are you like tattling
you know like come to me and talk and
like we'll figure it out you know for
like personal grudges exactly yeah cuz
like I was um you know I like at UH at
my yoga studio I were
or I don't work there but I go there to
do yoga and like one of the guys at the
front desk he was like hey let me ask
you guys something about something like
in this in this class like a couple
weeks ago did you guys experience any
weird something and like I was like wait
you mean like this thing yeah and he's
like yes that thing and I was with my
girlfriend and she was like yeah that
thing and he's like yeah people came up
to us and like complained about it and
and like basically he was just being
like guys this class freaking hard like
look around you and like some people
aren't working out to the best of their
ability some people aren't working out
at all like I have to ask yourself why
are you stopping
why why are you not working out right
now is it because did you stop because
someone else stopped and like apparent
all these people complained about it
that the guy challenged them and be like
hey what exactly the thing okay
and it's like well well what about that
the dudes job like is he is he gonna
lose his job because all these people
complaining and you know I'm saying and
like versus they could have just gone to
him like hey look I you know didn't
appreciate stuff so man I think that
it's true I wish right I wish we'd all
be like hey [ __ ] that one time you said
that it hurt I'd like to talk about it
well thanks for telling me Jimmy I will
keep that in mind for future but think
about how hard like I don't even tell my
dog about some of my problems you know
what I mean like it my dog doesn't even
understand me yeah I think it's just
hard for humans to bridge that gap and I
think the easier sometimes the easier
way is just to post to tweet or
something about like so-and-so did this
and I think it's true it's gonna be the
roughest before it gets better I think
right now we're in I think people need
to understand this too like whatever
state that the world is in now the very
divided polar opposites screaming about
stuff it's not gonna be like this
forever but in terms of things like the
me2 movement and the things like knowing
more about like people like Harvey
Weinstein like sometimes you do have to
like drop a bomb of knowledge and
information for something to change but
it doesn't mean that that's how it's
always gonna happen people are gonna
follow in that example I think for a
while which is like so-and-so did this
oh I'm gonna stalk about that person in
the same way or someone else in the same
way because I saw it happened like this
before but I think we've even seen now
people are tempering how they do it very
slowly over time but it's true I think
there's a lot of damage that can be done
that doesn't necessarily have to be done
just as a matter of evolving how we the
discourse we have about it and that
takes a lot of time and hopefully people
will be smart enough to slowly evolve
the way that they do it as well to fit
that well my friends made a comment that
we as a species as a culture we weren't
equipped to suddenly be presented with
differing viewpoints loud differing
viewpoints in our faces all the tall of
the time every day before the internet
that's something that you would have to
actively seek out right I wanted to have
a debate or discussion I would have to
okay I'm looking for some disagreement I
want to hone my opinion on something or
whatever you literally get a soapbox and
put it in front of a park like that's a
way that you could do it yeah or you'd
invite a discussion or something like
that you know yeah
politics over Thanksgiving kind of thing
now it's just like I can be browsing
Twitter and so I just blast me with like
oh oh I didn't know that but now I Gary
much disagree with that yeah now I'm
angry like yeah I don't know how do you
think how do you think people should
react that how do you think it like is
that something where people should do
you think people should be tempering
what they're saying I think that we as
it's almost impossible to ask society at
large to temper what they're saying
because I have been on the fiery side of
things plenty of times myself and found
myself receiving all sorts of crazy
backlash as a result I don't know it's a
question that I don't think we can
necessarily answer until the world gets
a little better at answering it then wow
what a long-winded way to say I have no
idea
I think the number I would just tell
everyone that your opinion is great and
it's valuable it's not the end-all
be-all and it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's the only opinion like we've
already talked about on this show and I
think before making a statement it would
be good to investigate a little further
before like making up your minds and
actually investigating like trying to
erase any preconceived notions you might
have and figure out what's really going
on like I think a really good example is
unfortunately that Jesse's small it guy
you know lied about the fact and hired
people to attack him and pretended you
know
was a racially based attack by Trump
supporters and it's like if that
actually happened that would be awful
but the fact that someone had to fake it
and then we had in all this stuff where
everyone was you know defending him and
then P and then and then real when
people realized it was wrong there was
like oh crap now what do we do like do
we do we blast him do we do we hold him
accountable for his actions like yeah
you treat him like you would anyone on
either side of the fence right like you
treated the exact same you don't treat
it more or less so because it was a
liberal that started that or if it was a
Republican originally you know you just
still treated the same like they're just
a human being that did something really
stupid so how do we react to that not oh
because he's a liberal we're gonna do
this it's like no that none of that
actually applies to the situation here
because this can happen on both sides of
the fence absolutely and it has now and
like I think that's the thing that
people you can't be self-righteous about
what you're representing because humans
are humans we're all gonna be really
dumb and do really dumb stuff no matter
where our political affiliations lies so
I think that's better they just try and
treat people as baseline humans try to
look beyond as much you can in terms of
preconceived notions and go from there
yeah and I think it's always healthy to
avoid an us-versus-them mentality it's
not about your team and helping your
team it's not a sports game yeah it's
not a sports game I mean literally we're
all humans and rolling it together I
know that the end the problem is that
the world has decided that you know
certain privileges will be granted to
certain races and genders just based on
how a society's patriarchal or how
society has been to predominantly one
way or the other for the longest time
but like those are the things I think we
have to move past and it's it's hard
it's really hard I think it's tougher to
understand too if you've been in it and
you don't it's hard to see out started
to see like your life from a holistic
top-down viewpoint yeah if you have been
that privileged person or whatever and I
think that's where a lot I mean that
we're getting so deep into the weeds now
in terms of like what we're getting into
but ultimately I the main takeaways just
view people as human as a literal
species not about color or race
orientation political orientation any of
that stuff yeah also travel go go take a
break in travel different country okay
traveling is traveling is one of the
best ways to understand that we're all
in it together for sure and it's not the
same everywhere
it's not the same everywhere and
yeah it's good to challenge in yourself
and get uncomfortable as hard as it is I
know that the Internet and the
convenience we have on our hands makes
life really easy to just kind of
disappear into like this nice comfort
zone
yeah but challenge yourself you're gonna
be a better person and you're gonna find
better everything better
love in your life and better
relationships better everything down for
that mm-hmm we have a lot more to talk
about I know I was wondering I should
keep going on this train of like now
let's let's change it up I think we yeah
what our pilot was comments final one
ending steam and the question it's a
question I asked Phil wing but it keeps
us keeps us going down this hole but
screw it here we go I like it all aboard
choo-choo all right it feels a great guy
um so you're talking about oh by the way
Phil another person who has had a long
history in LA in YouTube and whose
company has changed and split up and
stuff doesn't mean that these people
hate each other he just means that they
all want the different ways for whatever
reasons nobody talks about that podcast
great with us yeah go check it out if
you haven't listened to it youtube.com
slash quarter jingle podcast that's
nothing actually a URL that's something
we're all so I wanted to ask you in
terms of you talk about privilege and
you know ethnic biases and racial biases
and kind of stuff representation what do
you think is more effective in combating
that lack of a better term force
diversity or at least trying to meet
diversity quotas or diversity
representation 1% of the population is
this than 20% that should be that you
know or trying to completely ignore race
or ethnicity making that something where
it's apps and for example from a job
application and going only on the merits
of the job so I know for a fact that for
certain performing arts schools if
you're going to audition they do it
blind so let's say you're a violin
player you go into the room and you're
gonna play the violin
for people that listen to you but they
can't see you they can only hear the
music that you're doing right so that's
more along the lines of what you're
saying which asks purely on merit purely
on all that
we did the the corridor crew editing
position because chronicles headed out
all we had was send us the link to your
reel that's it not your real but your
the edit we did footage like yeah yeah
um I think there's a lot of things at
play here right one it would be awesome
if we could blank slate everything start
from new no one had prior investments no
in the private companies to worry about
knowing that prior earnings investors
all that stuff to report to they just
start from fresh and did that that would
be perfect that'd be awesome
unfortunately that's not the case
because you have companies that are run
by people that have been running it for
20 years
with prior relationships with people
that need certain things and need their
there are people cast in things or need
to make this project about that so as a
result I think the system has already
been built up to the point we're doing
it in that blind way isn't going to
enact the actual change you want because
it's just gonna follow what the system
is pre-built before it it's like trying
to change something that's it's it's
like trying to say like okay cool like I
have a machine that spits out 20 balls
every minute 19 of them are white and
one of them is not alright cool now
we're gonna just try and change the
system that it's not gonna do this
anymore it's like well the system's
still very much used to spinning out 19
white balls and one not white one so I
think that having that is a idealistic
and a good way to approach it in certain
scenarios but I think when you're trying
to combat like a super old system one
like Hollywood that's been around for a
long time that has a lot of pre-built
everything you're going to end up just
creating more of the norm and and maybe
you will push the dial in the right way
but I don't think it's gonna be as fast
as trying to be much more forceful about
in the first place but ultimately that
doesn't none of this matters because the
only thing that really matters and talks
in Hollywood is making money mmm and
that really the big decider of what's
gonna change and crazy rich Asians made
a lot of money and it did so at a point
in history when I think it was finally
the right time in the correct time in
the appropriate time for everyone to
realize oh okay this is an audience
that's been underserved for a long time
and they're actually hungry and they
want more of this kind of content as a
result I mean if you keep up with
casting news
there have been Asian names popping up
left and right right because people are
realizing oh you
what it's not so much been like we
should here our diversity factors it's
more like this is a money-making
opportunity and we would be stupid as a
business corporate identity whatever you
whatever it is to not at least try and
figure out how we can make money as well
off of this and and if it promotes
diversity and the people that are doing
it or have that goal in mind from the
first place awesome but I can assure you
a lot of these companies aren't like you
know what we need to hit our diversity
factors and it just so happens that we
have one that makes a lot of money you
know it's more just like cool this helps
us out in terms of public image but
there are a lot of great benefactors out
there that have had this mission from
the first place which is like we want
equal representation and as a result now
we're finally at the point where we can
push for it that's great right so I
think it's it's a tough question to
answer because it depends on every you
know where you're coming at it from I
think that's a fine answer
I honestly be nice more people answered
questions like that with it depends on
the situation which is a very viable
answer but apparently nobody accepts
that these days it's not a real yeah you
know it's like oh it depends on the
situation oh so you don't to answer the
question huh I don't know it's tough I
also don't know enough right about how
the world actually works still even at
thirty one to like be able to really
answer it I just know what based on my
experience and what I've seen and how I
feel about it that's also a good point I
wish people would answer questions based
on their experience as opposed to like
oh I know everything and oh my god let
me tell you you know that's good that's
good
I think that's something that comes out
of the fact that we have the entire
world's knowledge right here yeah and as
a result you get confident in khakha the
entire world's knowledge or the entire
world's preconceived notions aha we
decided yeah I mean it's all there right
so I think curling up with that I think
you you get the sort of I'm entitled
sort of / I know every know-it-all
mentality because you technically can
know with all would give me five seconds
you know so I think that that's
something that well I've read the
headlines and at least ten articles so
therefore know what I'm talking about
I read the front page of Reddit today
and I understand the Mueller
investigation whoo boy all right I like
that question that's a good question
thanks thanks TV thanks for answering it
any that's a delicate one to answer and
you did a I think a good job Thanks
do we want to uh we want to get into
that move that move along I'd be king of
our you know he's no move on not yet not
yet okay okay stay tuned because stick
around because time there's a you were
traveling down this history of alright
we're still in the history yeah and then
we got diverted for a minute just for a
minute here on some just some white
things to talk about so where are we at
right now yet so we're at the point
where Brandon has left rocketjump mhm
in Rock Jim's been doing this thing for
a couple months and this is the part
that I just kind of want to kick back
and here you to reminisce for a while
and that's the point at which both of
you guys were at rocketjump after the
split oh so this is the shorts team then
right shorts this is what is the shorts
team so there is stuff that happened
before the shorts team so Clint was
stayed with the team sort of split off
right Brandon took a couple people
afraid took old people and Clint was one
the people that one with Fraser
rocketjump and so Clint was there for
actually a bit longer and I've always
been on the peripheral of that company
because I wasn't a part of the founding
members I wasn't I had no ownership
stake in it it was just me it was I was
watching my brother do his thing while I
did my thing independently on the side
and a lot of that comes from just like I
was an actor I was trying to do my own
stuff and frein I would talk and
interact but it wasn't you know I didn't
want to be involved in his company
necessarily and he had his own thing
going from the beginning but Clint was a
big part of that
going into rocket gym so I would see
Clint quite often right I we would work
on stuff together it will either be a
game high school or I would be there
when you guys are filming shorts I help
them find their first office space up in
North Hollywood
I don't know that yeah I was the reason
that Nerdist was there too we shared an
office with Nerdist for a quick a quick
second and so during that time I was
always on the sidelines and sort of
helping out in every now and then coming
in doing some social media stuff I ran
like the Kickstarter campaigns for
season two and three billion high school
and a lot of email that up dude yeah and
after all that we moved to a new larger
office and Freddie in those guys were
like you know what we want you know we
don't want to just give up making shorts
because we're doing all this
longer for himself it doesn't leave us
time to make short films on the channel
so we're gonna make what we call a short
steam which comprised of me Clint
Ellery porterfield who played key on big
game high school and the siblings
Anthony and Ashley birch and that was
sort of their idea of like you know what
we'll take what you guys want to do
which is like we'll give you the
opportunity to make cool short films for
the channel and this also helps us keep
up consistent content on the channel and
this is probably four or five years
after Brandon left to do gaming stuff so
this is a significant amount of time
later during that time though was vo
game high school seasons two and three
that's sort of what took up the bulk of
the time and Clint was sort of there
doing some of the short film stuff yeah
I was I was shot bought in in Buick in
my school I was helping with VFX on
video game high school and I was
occasionally making shorts for the
channel like there was like a ping-pong
one you guys did yeah so like me and
Freddy would code direct a lot of stuff
together and you know I I love doing V
effects so that was you know that was
something I was doing as well editing
and doing the effects and just helping
with anything that needed to get the
videos out right so right that was the
interim yeah and during that interim I
was still doing vilgum high school but I
was also hosting a lot of stuff and
around that time I started the podcast
for Magic the Gathering called the
command zone with Josh leak why
and that's when Clem was in office and
stuff too so we all started doing more
stuff and then the shorts team came
around when I cool let's do the shorts
team together for a year so that was a
quite the fun adventure I think because
it didn't last a year it lasted about
seven months yes that must and then it
kind of fell apart and I learned a lot
from that which is like one you can't
have decision by committee you need to
have a clear direct like vision from the
top down then just pursue that and we
had five very talented people in the
same room together all with very
different levels of filmmaking
experience and I think that actually
hampered us in a lot of ways because
yeah everyone was given an equal say in
the room and as a result a lot of things
just didn't get done right you would
find yourself in a quagmire I just get
stucked in a stagnant state everyone
been like I have an idea and we all have
an idea about this idea and now we're
just like locked yeah we can't move
anywhere because any time we move
somewhere someone's like oh boy about
this you know so
like a constantly pushing and pulling
but you're never actually taking the
idea anywhere yeah we still were able to
make a bunch of really cool shorts but
the best ones we made honestly where
someone being like this is the idea
let's do it right and then we would just
jump into it without having spent too
much time toiling over what it was and
making sure it was perfect and yeah and
refining and refining it to the point
where it maybe wasn't as great as when
it started because that's that's like
let you literally have a direction I'm
gonna do this like tell me what just
just tell me what to do and I'll do my
best job you know yeah and that's when I
think you get the best work as opposed
to like you were saying everyone's like
well I know yeah hey let's have everyone
write this and it should what it should
have been like Clint this is a short
you're gonna direct I'll be your DP this
person is gonna edit it and this person
is gonna write it got to that point at
the end it's what yeah towards the end
it did but it was tough because we kind
of went into it without that direction
but it's one of those things where it's
like you can't learn until you do it do
it and you face the fire and you run
yourself into the ground trying to
figure it out so what was your what was
your impression of the shorts team when
you were told hey we want you to do this
and we want for the next year you're
going to make a short every two weeks
with these other four people what was
your what was your feeling on that my so
because I've always sort of trod to my
own path and had my own stuff going on
right item it was like this is cool I
don't want this to take over my life but
also I really do cherish the opportunity
to do something that slightly higher
budget and could look better and look
cooler and you know be on rocket gem
that's a great distribution platform
right so I think I went into it and is
the excited and ready to just tackle
whatever was given and I think what
ended up happening is that all of us
found ways to prioritize the other parts
of our life over the short steam in
different ways and then we found just
the right amount of time to put into the
short steam because at first it was like
an all in effort we were all there on
time every single day in the morning I'm
ready to go and very slowly as you know
the problems I was talking about we were
run into which is like we all get stuck
on the point or we couldn't figure out
how to move past it you'd find that
people would you know like me especially
I'd come in a little later I'd work a
little less on this because someone else
I thought was handling it and things
sort of degraded because there wasn't
enough
I think single leadership and that's
something that I it was very
important lesson and it's the kind of
lesson that happens it's always
hindsight is twenty-twenty with a lot of
this stuff and I'm sure you found this a
lot nico where it's you guys have run
teams here now right and sometimes if
you're like can't you just go and do it
and do it by yourself figure it out like
I'd that's all I want to say right even
me now looking at my life working with I
look at me like can't you just figure it
out it's like no you gotta be there
alongside that process the whole time
and I think that's one of the
fundamental mistakes that a lot of
people make and the shorts team was one
of the versions of that which is you can
may have a great idea but ideas are just
words on a piece of paper the execution
is really where everything comes
together and the execution for the
shorts team I think was unfortunately
mishandled because it's just really hard
to get to put that amount of extras
right like Freddie Mac those guys made
the shorts team because they wanted less
work on their plate exactly really what
it did generate was more work on their
plate to make sure it did the thing you
wanted to before it became less work on
your place yeah it needed a leader and I
think one thing that helped so much was
cherish yes we had an amazing person she
produced she kind of produced and kind
of like managed us after after like the
I don't know two or three months she was
like guys like after every short we got
together and we were like what went well
what didn't work and then how can we how
can we better it for ya and what can we
do for next time exactly and that was
like boom that helps so much yeah but
the thing is cherish was also pulled in
two directions because she was working
on rocketjump film school at the time so
it's tough because it felt overstaffed
and understaffed simultaneously yeah and
there's a lot for me like I value that
experience a lot because I learned a lot
in terms of how to manage a project and
to do all that stuff I think one thing
that we could have done as a group at
the five of us is just one of us just
step up and de facto became a leader
yeah right and maybe that should have
been me for all things considered as I
had the closest ties to the company I
had the most experience outside of you
making these sorts of things in the
first place and making stuff for the
internet specifically but you know again
hindsight's 2020 and that the main thing
is I learned a lot from doing that and I
was just glad to be able to hang out
with Clinton more that was I did value
that quite a bit we hung out a lot
during that time you played a lot of
mario kart at
man dude the most Mario Kart in the most
Indian food I've ever had in a year was
that time at the waka jump shorts shorts
program and you introduced me to one of
my favorite games of all time I'm
actually wearing the t-shirt right now
hyper light drifter that the best like I
was like Jimmy what's that what's that
creepy like kind of peaceful music I'm
hearing right now and you're like dude
let me show you this game disasterpiece
D oh my god he's like the best yeah the
best and then yeah just tons of Mario
Kart we had this whole like challenge
thing or like we play Alya and even a
ally yes have you got first or second
place you could sit on the couch in my
living room and it's a nice couch dude
it is like super comfy if you got third
place it was a corner right there places
yeah corner wall said I think fourth
place was you have to stare at the
corner I think third place was you had
just you had to play it because we were
honored ESS you to play facing the
corner in the in the parents yeah and
there's a place you had the wall sit the
entire time yeah Porthos will just have
progressively worse and if you ever got
12th place ice bath oh really
did anybody ever get to know even close
dude member the one where you had to
hold your breath the whole race oh yeah
how intense was that that was fourth or
fifth place yet the pleasure breath the
interest no no it's possible it's
possible it's like we did it yeah yeah
yeah it was sometimes sometimes what two
three minutes and I would know that two
minutes is impossible to do we went
three and a half that was crazy yeah
and what else handstand you do upside
down was it upside down yeah you could
get like a hit stay on the couch yeah
but that was a lot of fun but yeah
looking back I think that was the big
takeaway ahead from all that and after
that rocket jump made a couple of shows
they made rocket jump the show as well
as dimension 404 and past that rocket
jump downsized a lot because they were
like okay cool or dump these shows we
don't need the space anymore we're just
gonna become a figure out what we want
to do next which is like you know we all
make a movie and this happens a lot like
JJ Abrams company's the same thing when
they're in a production that explodes
grows huge in size and when they're in
between projects it goes down to like
like five six people or something so
that's sort of this state that rocket
jumps in right now and meanwhile this is
when you guys started doing a patreon
start doing that core at sort of content
and I think in a different world rocket
jump could have taken a very similar
approach to what you guys did if I was
maybe in charge I maybe I would
thought that that was the right road to
go but I had so many things going on for
myself that it was hard to look beyond
what was given to me directly and it's
hard to because I wanted to focus mostly
on what I was doing mm-hmm
at that same time you know I right after
the shorts team finished I hosted the
show on Disney XD that was like a gaming
show that Clint was on we've got to film
some shorts for that stuff and I think
for me it was just like everyone has to
just keep pursuing their own path and
that's what happened rocketjump went
from this to that to this to that Clint
went from that here I went from this to
that and it's like we all still know
each other you know we'll still hang out
the cage we see each other at events or
you know get dinner do whatever it but
we're not literally living two feet away
from each other and talking every single
day I'm working and the distance in LA
is such that if you're even a mile away
from someone they may as well be in
another state sometimes and that's by no
fault of us right oh Allah I think it's
busyness busyness right and you have
your own priorities and things that you
want to do as a result you just lose a
little bit of a connection with the
people I mean the reason that we were
all so close and tighten it in the first
place is because we all literally lived
in the same room yeah you know and
that's what changed is that we just
moved and lived other places and pursued
our own what interested us the most
didn't mean that we hated each other
doesn't mean that we'd never want to
work with each other again you know Frey
did was it a Tentacruel with you guys
wait Tentacruel was did a Tentacruel
short oh yeah with what and he was
reloading a bunch of guns with all these
little crew logs tactical reloads you
know like that stuff still happens it's
just on the much less scale because
everyone's busy doing their own thing
and pursuing what makes them happy yeah
I have a great segue I'm talking about
moving on oh yeah so what you can't you
can't you can't like go all the way and
then come back he's grounded segue it
yeah okay okay so while you were talking
there I don't know what it was but you
reminded me that I was like three
royalty checks from you for you for you
they've been sitting in my frickin
little paper deal with pile there
probably for like $2 each by the way my
hoping one it's like 140
oh that's like two video games that's
that's like ten apex chests I've had
them for like three years
no there's no way they work anymore they
might yeah we'll check what's it right
before you leave I need to give them to
you but also I haven't seen you in like
a year because you've been in New
Zealand and that's why this they've been
sitting on my desk that's why that's why
yeah Jimmy why the heck were you in New
Zealand Jimmy did you make it I think I
made it guys
sometimes he came up with his saying
last weekend we went skiing which is
definitely made it then sometimes at the
top of the mountain sometimes you just
got to get it I cry looks wasabi at that
one I think he's gonna turn it into his
next leg catchphrase but that's great
dude yeah I was in New Zealand for six
months so last December December of 2017
which is almost two years year yeah it's
like a little over a year ago I found
out that I was going to be a part of the
live-action remake of Disney's Mulan
it's going to be the second it was it is
the second movie ever to be directed by
a female with a budget of over a hundred
million dollars the first was Ava
Duvernay
with the wrinkle in time I believe and
this is by Niki Caro who is an
incredible New Zealand director she did
movies like Whale Rider
she did the zookeepers wife
there was a Kevin Costner one about a
run at McFarland USA so she's done a lot
of stuff amazing director and I found
out I auditioned for it last November
and not this last November you before
that and I found that around December
but I couldn't say anything until I left
basically and then after I left I
couldn't say anything until it was
announced announced which was like last
August so I waited eight months to tell
people but I was in museum for six
months filming this live-action
adaptation I play the character of Ling
who if you guys remember the original oh
yeah three army friends that Mulan has
one of them looks like baymax one of
them is like short with a black guy and
then one of them is like the skinny or
middle person that is like always like
lovey-dovey and so that is the character
that mine is based off of that's great
dude yep so that was a very intense
period of my
life six months other people in the cast
list that you may recognize
so Mulan is played by a Chinese actress
named Crystal leo or the OFA who is a
very famous Chinese actress the Emperor
is played by Jet Li everyone's favorite
yes the commander of the army is played
by Donnie Yen and then there is another
character that is sort of the cohort to
the bad guy and she is played by Gong Li
who's another really famous Chinese
actress and the bad guys played by Jason
Scott Lee who is a famous American actor
he played Bruce Lee and dragged Enter
the Dragon dragging the Bruce Lee story
I think is was called what was that like
what and that's a that's a that's a
question that was a throwaway
Chan was in it too Jackie Chan is not in
ejections in another movie that I'm
doing it's called what what it's gonna
be a big year for Jimmy Wong coming up
everybody in 2020 it's somebody just got
to get it sometimes you just got to get
it close dude yes I'm gonna use that I'm
so using that sometimes but the best
part about that sense that it's just
sometimes right other times not now you
can you don't wanna get it it's
sometimes sometimes makes that war maker
sound like it's just something that you
voluntarily do once in a while yeah yeah
and it's yeah you make the decision so
the other movie that I'm in is called
wish Dragon it's an animated movie by
Sony Pictures animation it's gonna be I
think it's gonna be released worldwide
as well so that's basically a modern
retelling of the Aladdin story of a boy
that finds a lamp in this case a magic
old teapot that has a genie inside in
this case a wish dragon and he spends
those three wishes trying to reunite
with someone in his past and the way
dragon is Jackie Chan the wish dragon in
the Chinese version is Jackie Chan and
the American version is played by John
Cho I feel like this is gonna be the
good Aladdin like that's gonna be like
the good one seeing as I represent
another Disney movie I have no comment
on the current Aladdin that's coming up
is blue Will Smith just blew himself no
I just love the Tobias fugue a come up
from Arrested Development so yeah so
Jackie Chan actually has a small voice
role in the American version
but his company Sparkle roll or the
company is associated with Sparkle roll
had a part in producing it so that's why
he's gonna be a part of the Chinese
language version totally totally dude
that's that's amazing so this is like
for as far as I know I didn't get my
knowledge is limited as an actor it but
that's what I've heard that no dude it's
gonna pop off for you and like I suppose
so sometimes you just gotta get it man
um you're distracting it's going to be
watching Mulan and see me you're ruining
my live-action Disney experience are you
gonna think about like what memories are
gonna come up when you see me just like
doing my thing I'm gonna get so amped
I'm gonna scream in LA where we can
watch it together cuz all of the actors
live in LA - so we can all watch it
together rant and rave the whole time
dude well who in holler dude but yeah so
that was an amazing experience obviously
not only was the director female but so
was the director of photography the
first ad it was actually an the the
costume designer and there was a very
much a a female lead and completely
Asian cast right so like that was it was
groundbreaking in a lot of different
ways
mmm and it was really awesome to see it
just get put all together because I
think everyone had that shared there's a
kind thing you want where everyone knows
they're in it for this thing together
what was the hardest day on set the
hardest day on set there were two really
hard days and of course like actors we
were we were spoiled crybabies about
both of them we only had one night shoot
right normally there's a lot night
shoots on movies like this but there's
only a couple of things that times where
it needs to be nighttime and one of them
we were it was raining it was muddy
we had boots on that weren't necessarily
fully waterproof cuz I mean it look I
could have the most waterproof jacket on
in the world but if you soak it in water
for long enough it's not gonna come yeah
and so we kind of got to that point and
it sucked because though every time the
rain came you'd have to stop because it
would be on camera
you couldn't you never say to wait for
the rain to clear as soon as it did is
like alright everyone you and 300 other
extras background talent that our
soldiers and stuff everyone shuffle out
and get ready to do the scene rains
coming down crop shuffle back you know
so like that's that's tough as an actor
tuff is a crew member to of course these
actors if you're like my feet or wet and
cold like yeah how about the other 500
people have been saying this up for six
hours Jimmy how about how do you think
they feel but you know so that was crazy
it was also the biggest day I've ever
been on set I think there were like 600
700 maybe even 800 people there that day
it was crazy how do you manage so many
people I don't know people credit goes
to Nicky in the first ad and everyone
else for figuring it out because the
shoot still ran with it they did it they
did what they had to do they got the
shots they needed to get it was just it
was just a long night right and you know
as someone that's not the lead of a
movie you know you're a lot of times
you're reacting the stuff you're trying
to be in the moment
so that's tough too they like keep your
mental capacity at a at a pristine level
when it's 3 a.m. and you're freezing and
all this other stuff but that's kind of
what being an actor is so I can't
actually complain so it was a hard night
but I think is one of those character
developing ones and obviously huge
credit grows to everyone that actually
worked really hard to make sure it
happened and went off without a hitch
was there a place that your mind went to
when you were freezing and cold and
you're like I have to perform but like
yeah I think it was just seeing the fact
that you would maybe goes back to the
whole thing that Brandon said when you
saw the trailer on set you know for me
it was like not only are we walking onto
a set with a trailer Jimmy we're walking
to one set where 400 500 other people
have been working their asses off to
make it so that you can be in front of
the camera and you can have your face
there and you're also surrounded by a
you know hundreds of background talent
that I've been training as well to be a
part of this movie and they're all local
talent from New Zealand and they're all
Asian and they all understand just as
much that this is an important moment of
representation for them and for everyone
else that going to see them on screen
they have pride they're not complaining
why the hell are you complaining Jimmy
you know so like there was a lot of
different things that went into it like
tha you gotta just you you gotta get rid
of any negative thoughts in your head
right now because you have to trust the
process and trust that everyone out
there is doing what they can to make
this the best they can and that you're
gonna be a part of that so you should
you know put your best foot forward so
my mind often went to that place which
is gratitude
empathy and also just like very happy to
be there overall cuz it was unlike
anything I've ever done before
and that again was like the the magic of
being an actor and seeing a trailer on
set that that moment for me again it's
just interesting how different that can
be to different people for me it was
just like this is eat your humble pie
you know like how many people get to do
what you're doing right now don't don't
it sucks
you may feel gross you may get a cold
after this you may be cold you may be
complaining but it it's the ride that's
what that's what you signed up for kiddo
like that's that's what you think up for
kiddo Leonardo DiCaprio was complaining
when he got mauled by a bear and had to
crawl through the Tundra's no not Leo
not Leo so I mean I think that it's like
a log character formation stuff and
being able to do a movie with people for
six months right like two months it was
just actual training meeting with people
and learning lines and doing all that
stuff
and the other four months were going
into straight production it was
obviously been like going into war
together and it felt that way because we
were being trained as soldiers for a war
you know and that's what the movies
about so you do martial arts training at
horse training archery all sorts of
training I I can now proudly say that I
could write the hell out of a horse no
saddle no I want to sell you kidding me
bro bareback that thing that sounds nuts
I can ride the hell out of a horse I'm
in the best shape of my life and you
know like those are the things that like
how could I not be absurdly grateful to
the people that helped make that a
possibility you know it and throughout
the process I'm seeing my culture what
my parents grew up in the world they
grew up in represented in across every
single aspect from the production design
the costumes to the to the wardrobe
that's names costumes to the set design
to the weapons to every single part of
it was they had done their research and
they did so much research into making
this historically accurate and also
something that represented the culture
that they were doing because like think
about Nikki Karl is a white woman and
Mandy Walker is the DB is a white woman
directing a movie about China right like
there are so many times where he can be
like that that's not gonna go well but
they took the care in time to make sure
that it was fully 100% representative of
what they're trying to do and paying
respects as well as breaking new
boundaries so that for me it was like a
really surreal moment to see someone
else reaching out like that and
and really putting their best foot
forward no one's doing it just for a
paycheck right they're doing it because
they want to take pride in the work that
they're doing and is someone that
creates stuff and the friends will be
able to create stuff that's like the
best thing you could ask for so when
you've worked with people like I don't
know if you had any scenes like jet Li
for example consuming it seems it Donnie
Yen it's considering you're playing a
soldier yes and you can safely assume
that I won't say as a soldier in the
army and as the commander of the army
they're probably scenes where we are
close by or near each other I'm also
going to guess as playing one of Milan's
friends you probably have scenes as the
lead actress of the piece as well
correct
having worked with these people that
previously to this point were people
that you've only seen on the silver
screen
you know these larger-than-life
characters yeah has it humanize them in
a way like do you see them as regular
people or do you see them as he's like
level 20 charismatic barks it's crazy I
you know I came to love every single
person I worked with it was very much
like a family where you hate some people
you know they mean like it's I'm sure
it's the same for you and Sam right
there are points when you're just like
oh there he goes again or he doesn't
same for you but at the end of the day
you would jump from a bullet for that
man right well maybe not basically I ran
a fast-moving baseball like like at 90
miles per hour fast bit nice nice yeah
well cried a couple bones but it won't
actually murder you yeah I'm that with
that
so getting to interact with all the cast
and crew in that way I think was really
important because it did humanize
everyone you know we got to spend a lot
of time with these people off set when
they weren't in work mode where they
weren't there and you know focusing on
what they need to do and obviously
everyone needs to take you know I think
some of the people so everyone treated
differently some people didn't really
like to hang out as much other people
only went for special occasions but when
you did it it's you know I got this
question on Instagram the other day and
I really I understand why people ask the
question but I did test it which is like
how does it feel to be famous and for me
that question just it gets me like hot
and bothered because you know now that
I've been so Lilly Fay for instance
she's been doing movies since she was 16
in China and she's one of the biggest
stars they're by far
she has 56 million people that fall
we're just on her Facebook equivalent
Wow right like Logan reality check buddy
so you know this is the kind of person
that we would go out occasionally all of
us as a group maybe to get ice cream or
something and you could just see people
having a freakout once they recognize
who she was and this is in New Zealand
where there are Chinese people there but
it's not the main population not by a
long shot so you could tell that there
is obviously like that kind of pressure
on that person to you know maybe that's
why they don't want to go out so much is
because it's yeah people would come up
and you know you want pictures
signatures all that stuff and you can
tell like that's intrusive it sucks and
we've all been in that position but we
earned that position when we like go to
VidCon yeah it's a place where people
know they're gonna see us once a month
once a month we happen to be walking
through a mall or a place that has our
target demographic this person literally
can't go anywhere without people
freaking out dude that must that life
must be crazy yeah and so when people
ask me the question like what's it like
to be famous and I've been able to hang
out with people that are of all
different influential levels and in
different celebrity levels and stuff I
just see humans I just see people that
grew up were born the same way you and I
were raised in pretty similar settings
you know who suffered the same stuff
maybe had the same embarrassing moments
happen to them and I think at the end of
the day that's the takeaway I had about
all these people is just like at the end
of the day they're just they're as human
as the rest of us and these are people
that grew up in a completely different
society in China that's completely
different culturally in America but
there's still just baseline humans at
the end of the day and I think that's
the thing that resonates with me the
most when I get asked that question
which is like I don't want to consider
myself more special than any of you
because it doesn't make me feel good and
I'm sure it doesn't make you feel good
either like we're all in this together
it's the same sort of thing we harken
back to it earlier in the show which is
like it's all a group effort here guys
like we're all human we're all gonna
feel the same way a lot a lot of stuff
and ultimately like empathy is the thing
that I that I learned a lot from hanging
out with these Quantico mega stars
that's awesome that like they're just as
human as the rest of us they like to
laugh love and enjoy life and you know
talk about things and interact and not
be treated or put on the pedestal I
think where you get a lot of what
happens with divas is that people put
you know celebrity stuff on the pedestal
and start
get away with things and as a result
that deteriorates their behavior over a
longer time and you know from what I
could tell hanging out with these people
that you could always see elements of
how that's happened and you can also
just see that they're humans at the end
of it and if you can treat them like a
human you're gonna you're gonna just
blow right past all the things that may
have created bad behaviors in people and
I even felt myself going down the Daeva
route right hmm you are I was number 11
on the cast list I think and who knows
that might change these things always
switch around but it was enough that
people knew who I was and there I walked
in anywhere and if I asked for something
I generally got it
Wow Wow so and you know I felt myself
going down the road very slightly a
night complete I was very quickly was
like whoa I can't do that anymore
whereas like I walk into a place where
I'd need something and I asked for it in
a way that was not Jimmy yeah you know I
asked for in a way that was like actor
that needs his thing my shoes are too
tight my feet hurt they're cold you know
that sort of stuff that like normally
you would just like you I think a lot of
the times it was just I had to see other
things happening for me to realize in
context of my own actions how it how I
was like oh I don't like how that how I
act it in that way well for instance
done that night it was really cold and
wet and rainy all these other people
behind me hundreds of people that have
been training and are doing it for you
know low pay
comparatively right to what like the the
big shot so we're never gonna make and
they're all they're not complaining
smiles on their faces interacting with
each other having a blast they're
working on an incredible movie and Here
I am you know in my little actress
circle me like ha is lucky I don't wanna
be like that dude what a check man do
you turn behind you people were just
like happy there's they were a lot of
checks honestly doing a movie like this
on this scale for the first time and I
would say I'm pretty used to production
right I've done a lot of different
things on different sizes I mean on
different movie sets TV sets all that
stuff and this being in another foreign
country was just something unlike I've
ever experienced before so there are a
lot of times where I felt embarrassed
about how I acted in a scenario and felt
you know what I you know I didn't handle
that right at all how can I make amends
how can I make it better and a lot of
the time it was just do your job bro
yeah we hired you for a reason do that
job try not try to make it easier for
everyone sure but ultimately you're here
to do that job so try and do that and I
think that was the big takeaway I got
from all that that's cool
man I like it makes me really happy to
hear you say that because I mean you're
one of my best friends and like to see
to see my friends like with that
awareness and that level of humility
like that that's awesome I really
respect that
this was great it's tough I think one of
the things I learned too is we trained
intensely for two straight months before
we even went into filming and we're
talking some of the hardest physical
training I've ever done in my life
they couldn't you might say they made a
man out of me I learned that so much of
the battle that we fight is mental
because a lot of times our trainer would
we're working out crazy right then Trey
woke up to and I let's say Clint imagine
your room when you're really hard
workouts you or a yoga class where you
are at the breaking limit yeah totally a
scale of one to ten where are you ten
being you've passed out I've been doing
at eight and eight yeah like a buck
throw up if I keep going off throw up or
something that's a that's close she's
like nine ten if you're about to throw
okay so let's say that you would just
started doing yoga and I ask you the
same question Clint where are you right
now 1 to 10 oh I'm gonna 10 right now
like I'm maxed out right so what when we
first started asking that question to us
we were like oh he's doing it so that he
can we can tell him where we feel and
engage it yeah but what I realized over
time is that he wasn't asking the
question for him to know he's a top
level trainer coach he knows exactly
what you're going through him what your
limits are he's asking because he wants
to know where you're putting yourself at
that exact moment Yeah right so like if
you think I'm in a 10 he's like this
kids at a 5 okay that's what he thinks
yeah and that's his mental state and
that's where I have to work as a coach
slash trainer to get them to wherever
they need to go I learned a lot through
that training which is just like you are
the person that is truly in control of
yourself if you in situations like that
right like your brain could push you to
not do anything and to stop and quit or
it could be the thing that drives you to
completely blow whatever you're doing
out of the water and put your absolute
best foot forward and that if you want
to bring yourself to a 9 or a 10 you
could what is holding you back from
doing it it's often yourself so that was
like one of the big takeaways I learned
from that and I you and I think that
applied to the more I trained the better
I got at realizing that I was either
acting out of line or being
inconsiderate or
you know a diva and whatever aspect a
lot of that training helped me realize
that and that honestly like you if you
put your mind to something you can
accomplish it and it's like sounds so
cheesy to say like the corniest thing in
the world but it's like one of those
things that unless you really took like
I found myself at the absolute breaking
point of my spirit and body multiple
times and I found out that I could push
myself past that that's awesome dude
right and so that lesson is something
that I will apply for the rest of my
life which is like there will be times
when things get real bad and this is why
I particularly empathize with people
that have like depression or anxiety
because I'm saying all this stuff if you
put your mind to it you can accomplish
it whereas there a lot of people out
there we're like I have an actual
chemical imbalance in my brain where
that is not possible sometimes so that
makes me really empathize with people
with those kinds of like mental issues
health issues and but it's something
that I'm gonna try and ply for the rest
of my life and at least preach to other
people which is like it really is a
battle between you and your own mind
when you are losing and when you're
stopping a workout who's winning who are
you laying take control and it's often
your brain telling you I don't want to
do this anymore
so for me it's like that was a big part
of learning okay Jimmy you acted out of
line here how can you make this better
how can you control yourself how can you
make sure that you don't take the same
misstep so you the last time and reframe
this it's all in your head right your
head drives your action I totally agree
yeah I'm like I was saying earlier I'm
reading the this book by an ex-navy seal
David Goggins mhm and this dude is
insane and he's talking about all the
seal training how he's pushed to the
brink constantly yeah like yeah running
on broken shins and and whatnot and like
it's all in the game like it's it's all
in his head and like the game for him is
training his mind mm-hmm you know yeah
was mind training in our our trainer /
coach harped on that constantly you know
yeah I believe it man that's awesome
like and the big thing he would always
say is focus on yourself in workouts we
do group workouts and we'd all be there
and we'd all be like oh Lord
but the moment that we've turned the
other person be like yeah and I show up
nice you book stop what are you why are
you congratulating that person focus on
yourself why are you are you done
working well want you why don't you do
five more come on like don't waste your
time
I'm focusing on someone else and
congratulating them and make them feel
better leave that to them right this is
a personal journey for all of you yes
and you're gonna be better calm the
camaraderie is gonna be better if you
all get to that point together that you
have figured out how to control your own
mind and get to that point and then you
can like really you know you can you
guys can hang out the moment the
training is done you guys can go get
dinner you can go laughs and good drink
do whatever you want but that when
you're in the training focus on yourself
focus on what makes you what works for
you what doesn't and try to make
yourself better in that moment that's
all another great takeaway that's so
it's such a unique experience that you
had yeah hopefully more hopefully more
to come hopefully more and I think you
know the reason I really want to do this
podcast is because I like getting the
word out and telling people about things
that I've learned it's a reason I do
what Magic the Gathering podcast is that
it's a informative way to provide value
to people and I think podcasts are one
of the you know best ways to tell people
in the world about something that you
learned help maybe change the culture a
little bit by hammering a point home the
it we all have to contribute in some way
sometimes sometimes you just gotta get
outta get on the quarter cast - that
youtube.com slash quarter cast with Sam
and ego I'm Clinton I'm Clinton
and clicks my name's Clinton youtube.com
slash - my name's Clinton youtube.com
slash quarter cast use that calm slash
quarter cast youtube.com/ that corner
cool YouTube corridor cast calm quarter
cast calm /youtube you've heard of
Maslow's hierarchy of needs yes like
food water shelter and all the way at
the top and that little Keystone at the
tip top of that pyramid is fulfillment
mmm-hmm
are you standing on top of that pyramid
right now yeah I would like to think so
yeah
if you quit acting tomorrow would you
walk away from this from this being like
you know what I did it yes I think so
I when I first moved to LA in 2011 I
told myself I'd give myself 15 years to
break it as an actor and I was like if I
can't make it in 50 I think that's a
long enough time to not be naive and say
like I'm gonna do it the next two years
I think that's it was the right amount
of time to say like okay if I'm
finding real success as an actor by this
point then I'll just do something else
I'll figure out what my passions are and
I'm gonna try and formulate those
passions while I'm here in LA and a lot
of that has been content creation music
hosting a lot of that stuff and I found
a lot of success in different realms
like hosting I've done you know I've
named the host live events at PAX I've
been able to host cooking shows and food
travel vlogs across the world and do a
bunch of different things in that world
I've been able to act in stuff like
video game high school and now Mulan and
Ben with a voice acting things like wish
dragon so I think in terms of my
personal fulfillment which is you know
like I would say my 6-year goal is to
have a real lasting impact for Asian
male representation and as an actor I
think my goal would be win an Oscar as a
best actor Asian like be the first Asian
male to win an Oscar mm-hmm as an actor
that'd be amazing
and so I think for me fulfillment is is
taking the things that I've learned and
what I have in my life and being able to
change the world in a significant and
meaningful way that makes it better for
other people specifically for you know
young me growing up who didn't have the
kind of role models that my friends did
I had all my role models for the romance
stuff were white very much like I love
James Bond I loved rocky right like I
loved all these sort of heroes and icons
and for me I love Jackie Chan too
obviously I love Jet Li I loved all
those old kung fu flicks but it was
about the fighting it was about the
martial arts that they did and it wasn't
about the connection with a human or
that that sort of like Western
humanistic element that it's in a lot of
our cinema so I think my real
fulfillment is going to come from being
able to change the world in a way that
lets young kids that look like me and
have a cultural idea these similar than
you grow up and say cool that's
something that makes me more confident
because you know I've seen someone else
do it and it's been told in stories
already mm-hmm you know I was severely
unconfident when it came to talking to
like women and girls in high school I
looked young I you know I I went I
didn't eat the food that they ate my
thing here Jimmy yeah yeah same
but a lot for a lot of that you know for
me it wasn't helped by the fact that I
couldn't model myself I didn't feel like
I had a real model role model for me
that looked like me and I know it sounds
silly if it doesn't happen to you or if
you don't feel it in the same way but I
think a lot I think that is a real
problem for a lot of people and
especially like I think young women too
growing up for the longest time like
think about and Disney's on the great
job to their credit of changing the
stereotype of like before they're just
helpless princesses kidnapped and forced
into this or that or would be asleep for
a thousand years till a guy came and
kissed them you know and with movies
like Moana and frozen they've changed
that paradigm to empower young women and
I think you've already seen the impacts
that that has in society in terms of you
know like that's the thing that always
makes me laugh which is like if you
can't even represent 50% of your society
you know good way how the heck are we
gonna get to the minorities mmm you know
so I think that taking that step first
in terms of having strong female figures
and that's why I've always loved Studio
Ghibli movies is because all those main
characters are strong independent women
I think that's the one of the
cornerstones of making a better world
for everyone is fine first get your
representation right for the largest
largest chunk of society because women
technically I think are like fifty point
something slightly higher percentage
wise and that might be due the evolution
just to make sure that we'll always have
more kids moving forward and more you
know offspring because that's where that
comes from but I think like if you can't
even get that part of representation
right then you're not gonna be able to
unlock the other ones past that so
that's like my fulfillment is knowing
that I was able to be a part of this
movie and like with Mulan but that has
an incredible female representation in
like a strong young woman that goes out
to fight for her family's honor and take
her father's place in the army and prove
to everyone that it's not about
male/female it's about you know what
your virtues are and how are you gonna
apply that to real life like that I
think is like whoa
can't wait agent like it's everything
that I was hoping for growing up I
remember with my grandma for some will
on the animated version she came away
from it upset visibly upset well because
this is a story that was told throughout
her childhood of the hers like sort of
Joan of Arc s character a huge hero in
Chinese history and it was turned into
her like a
a mockery of that you know there was a
talking dragon there was you know music
and songs and merriment and dance and
all these cultures and traditions that
were very valuable to her as a child
growing up and were taught to her but
seen in the cartoony way and I think
that was a you know a what happened
because of the time period it was the
90s a lot of the cartoons were like I
mean look at Shrek freights since like
you know we made movies that are more
silly and animated and stuff because
that's just kind of what the
entertainment says this was where value
was of that kind of movie and so I think
being able to revisit that story and
retell it in a way that I know my
grandma if she was still alive would see
it would be happy with like that means a
lot to me too so I think in terms of
being personally fulfilled it's being a
lot of boxes are being checked off but I
still haven't gotten to the point where
I'm like I really have done it I think
you're right if I retire tomorrow I'd be
like I had a great rug that was awesome
I ended on the bang mm-hmm but I want to
end on bangers you know I mean it's all
good you know sometimes just got good so
that's I mean I think that's those are
my ultimate goals is to really change
the societal status for Asians in
general you know I hate the stereotypes
that are made of Asian people I hate the
fact that we still you know mock and
have so many racist incidents happening
all the time you know I hate the fact
that Logan Paul who is on this very
podcast right yeah ran to Japan and
disrespected the hell out of that
culture like that's absurd and the fact
that millions of kids watch him and went
that's great I love that I would be like
that you know like let's move past that
it's not it's not you know we're an
international community the Internet has
bound the whole world together in a lot
of ways so we should try and be better
to the rest of the world that's a great
up closing thought here
what's your podcast so if you guys like
Magic the Gathering or want to see
multiplayer Magic the Gathering gameplay
you can look up the commands own podcast
command zone or look up game nights and
that's nights with a K on it and you'll
find all those episodes online if you
guys like cooking and food and want to
see foods from like Spongebob
Squarepants
or anime and movies made into real life
you can look up feast of fiction now
just called feast you can find all that
stuff online you can follow me on
Twitter Instagram all that good stuff
but yeah those are my main two outlets
of activity right now or the command
zone and a feast of fiction so if you
guys want more of me you can find there
great Jimmy it was a pleasure having you
in the podcast thanks so much yeah guys
thanks for watching I really appreciate
you guys sticking around
Jimmy's one of my very best friends so
it was a pleasure to have him on the
podcast and also to see you guys
recommend Jimmy in the comments if you
have anyone else do you guys would want
to see interviewed on the corridor cast
please leave a name down in the comments
we'll reach out we'll find a way we will
find a way guys if you haven't already
please subscribe to the corridor cast I
think the little Bell notification thing
as well so you guys know when we're
doing another podcast until next time
I'm Clinton Jones and I'll see you guys